the American president in His infinite
wisdom and poised leadership has
traveled all the way around the world or
halfway around the world to Asia
specifically to Japan yesterday to South
Korea today and he has the great honor
and responsibility of representing
America abroad in front of the Japanese
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a in front of
a BAE's wife and countless others the
Japanese Emperor and he was given the
opportunity to speak and he stated that
he didn't know there were so many
countries in the world until he became
president of the United States after of
course doing the hallmark of any Trump
speech which is bragging about the fact
that he won the election back in
November video of Donald Trump poised
representing us as a statesman around
the world in particular in Japan so my
relationship with Shinzo got off to a
quite a rocky start because I never ran
for office and Here I am but I never ran
so I wasn't very experienced and after I
had won everybody was calling me from
all over the world I never knew we had
so many countries if Barack Obama had
gone around the world just once to brag
about his electoral victory it would
have been a constant persistent series
of apoplectic reports from right-wing
media Trump does it daily and he's given
a pass and Trump is representing you
around the world he's representing
American citizens throughout our humble
planet and the one person who speaks for
us on this trip in Japan thinks to say
he didn't know there were so many
countries around the world
how is American exceptionalism being
advanced by our president flying around
the world to brag about his victory and
admit to confusion about the number of
countries on earth this is a man who can
barely string two sentences together
that make him sound anything short of
moronic and this was just the first stop
in his Asia trip
it is already an international
embarrassment he tells the Japanese
Emperor that mass shootings can happen
anywhere of course Japan has almost none
because they take the issue of gun
violence seriously and the real issue
here it's not really Trump right Trump
is the consequence of the problem the
root of it is not necessarily anti
intellectualism but pseudo-intellectual
ism which I've talked to you about
before I wish I could say that when
Trump goes abroad and does this that it
reflects only on Trump but the truth is
that it reflects badly on the voters
particularly the voters that voted to
put this guy in office this type of
nonsense rolls off of Trump's tongue so
casually and his supporters eat it up
could he possibly embarrass the United
States any more than he has already and
his supporters love him for this stuff
because he's the simple guy right he's a
man of the people despite being a
billionaire born with a silver spoon in
his mouth no one stops to think that
wait a second why is a 71 year old guy
who grew up infinitely privileged and
supposedly did well at a top university
he's talked about how great he did at
Wharton why is he so dumb why you don't
see the trumpets asking that and now you
really are getting to understand when we
see these abortive trips around the
world now I really get why someone like
Vladimir Putin would see Trump as a
candidate and say that is the perfect
mark to be manipulated by a hostile
foreign power these trips along with
just about everything this guy is doing
while he stateside they really are
illuminating why it is that Putin and
the Kremlin would take an interest in
Donald Trump as a potential President of
the United States send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show follow
us both I am super excited to tell you
that once again today's program is
sponsored in part by live lingua which
is an immersive language learning
platform where you actually learn a new
language from native speakers I was born
speaking Spanish and I learned English
as a Second Language I've studied
and Hebrew as new languages and the most
effective way to actually achieve the
language proficiency you want is to
speak directly to native speakers and
that's what live lingua does they will
match each student with a personal
teacher to work one-on-one on their
language learning goals there's no
gimmicks no promises that you'll be
fluent in a month by practicing only
five minutes per day live lingua is an
online language immersion school that
works with students aged 4 to 94 and
each student works one-on-one with their
teacher meaning there's no falling
behind the rest of the class every class
is taught by a native speaker of a
language that also speaks English and it
only costs a fraction of what a private
tutor would charge you you don't have to
spend time in traffic or commuting to
classes you meet with your tutor via
Skype and our viewers and listeners can
sign up for a free trial Skype lesson by
visiting live lingua com / Pakman live
linguist personal class coordinator will
contact you arrange a lesson that fits
your schedule with the teacher that's
best suited to your ability and learning
style and after the trial lesson you'll
receive a full evaluation and a proposed
curriculum personalized to your needs if
you want to continue live linguist
immersive language learning method is
convenient productive and built to meet
the needs of each student you can get
that free trial lesson at live lingua
Comm / PA que mas